في غضون ذلك قال سفير الروسي في واشنطن ان
تقديم الولايات المتحده مساعده جديده
لاوكرانيا اصرار على تصعيد الازمه وكان
وزير الخارجيه اعلن عن حزمه مساعدات
امريكيه جديده لاوكرانيا وقال ان الحزم
الجديد بقيمه الثلاثه مليون دولار وتهدف
لتعزيز دفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اضاف
انها تتضمن قدراتي دفاع جوي كبيره وذخيره
لانظمه الصواريخ والمدفعيه ومضادات
للدبابات
المتحده وحلفائها وشركائها سيقفون متحدين
لدعم اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر على حد
تعبيره
في اجتماع وزراء خارجيه حلف النيتو اليوم
سيركز على الدعم الذي يقدمه الحلف
لاوكرانيا من اجل التاكد من انها ستنتصر
في مواجهه روسيا سوف نواصل تعزيز
التحالفنا من خلال خطط الربع والدفاع كما
سنبحث عضويه السويد في الحلف ونتخذ قرارات
بشان كل هذه الملفات في قمه فيلينيوس
المرتقبه